[Music]
man said he's going to be sitting
outside your baby mum's yard
with dark food standing through his head
that's a bit like what [ __ ] his storms
he tried to do to chip come outside
manchester united
wow it should buy a lv general lumpet
slump it
might brothers don't eat crumpets man's
back with
lv generals track of the weeks yeah
today
man is gassed yeah bare people's comment
in this guy you know
man like potter pale
pot of paper you knew what i meant come
out of beans not long ago
we've done a little kenny all-stars team
the one so make sure you are subscribing
to stand that tv from the start
make sure you subscribe to my channel as
well and follow my socials
keep up to date with what's going on in
that and don't know a lot about my man
potter but
i know he's an old school rapper from
back in the day and he's been patterning
i know he's cousin though
he's got a cousin called kaz he lives
down the road for a man still
and he yeah man he's a real one still so
we got kaz as well
as for kenny all stars i know kenny i
went to my veterans thing
in formal clothing and yeah man good
times you get me so yeah man this is
something i should review anyway so
hello kenny
you saying voice in the streets man
that's mad man come out and these whole
grooves done chain on
got the boogers going they're the new
ones in the jordans like like man's
bathing blood do you look you look
healthy
[Music]
and you know what's so funny he does so
much like kaz he looks bad like his
cousin blood
that is mad now i'm seeing man's grill
i'm like
yeah bro that's man's family you can
tell anyway let me stick to the chat
sorry i'm going off sorry sorry
yo let's go time galaxy i think i'm nice
[Music]
done jail time but it blew by him
you know white blue blind because the
way he's now it's it's all happening so
fast but yet he's back out
he's living his life from and i'm not
trying to say ganja was a good thing
it's not
i don't represent that but i represent
man trying to change his life
that's what i represent you see me yeah
diamonds flash that's blue lights fight
on years in jobless
a dog's gonna run in dubai i rise
licking off shots it's mad it's immense
this guy is different i like him already
he's he's mad
like food fight nine years in job it's
three bites in a run in dubai
[Music]
too long man just close one eye and bow
and you know what
to do some freaking that bird shooting
thing like oh i weren't shooting birds
sorry
i was shooting the was that called again
disc something
oh clay piggy clay pigeon shoot okay
whatever it is but i didn't kill any
pigeons mate i had to close one eye
and i was using the launch the the
shotgun barrel thing so i don't know
what he whether he was on about that he
had to close one eye with the
but you know what i mean you know where
i'm going with it i don't squeeze on a
tin with one eye
pour on you you used to do it don't do
throws it's more than jesus said don't
do drugs it's more entrees
come outside you don't want a scene
watch
you [ __ ] yeah but you still get
touched don't business
with the big barrel don't do joe this
morning come outside you don't want
[Music]
coco you know what that one was i didn't
want to say the word
in case i get man in trot you want to
get man in try you know
mitch's means trouble but you don't want
to get my intro is
it me to break down the words for you
look
no no you're not doing this again you're
not doing this again you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of it but siri i didn't even
say the word siri you
all of a sudden made a noise
[Music]
what they made the chain out a real gold
fan or is that just me seeing gold plate
what the [ __ ] even the dog's bathing
sulfurman
[Music]
[Music]
repeat that one
[Music]
who
did you say free lv or they say free l
free
i said lv why say free me blood
why do i need freeing you're taking a
[ __ ] piss blood
he said free me go back he could never
told me free me
free me
[Music]
man all right well you know what i am on
some stuff but i don't know
i don't know if he's talking about me
mate i don't think he is he doesn't know
who i am
i've not been locked up he must be on
that there's another lv out there but
i'm obviously
the general of that lv general so all
the lvs out there you can hold that but
i am the general of the lvs
so we'll get that one out the way it's
not ascend
oh man come in my yard tries to come man
it's not that
hit and see me they don't want none
yeah i don't know you just got bombed
you slashed a man with catch free lv man
he's on some stuff
[Music]
this guy's mad fam don't [ __ ] with
potter
three young eyes awesome stuff guns get
busted
[Music]
in gloves that was sitting outside man's
baby mom's having some crazy ones like
whoa oh now it's got deep
man said he's going to be sitting
outside your baby mum's yard
with dark foot scan through his head
that's a bit like what [ __ ] storms he
tried to do to chip come outside
manchester united
this is crayfum this is what this is
what it is now though
2020 this is what it is some crazy ones
like
[ __ ] man's grindies hold t at me
man said no i'll come outside man's yard
on them crazy ones that that the dark
fool's going through his head like
that he's smiling and he nah he's nuts
he's he's not still [ __ ] old blood
you lot of problems
he smiled
[Music]
that one yo free effects that's bro bro
training day free no promo italian
follow my clothes whoa who the [ __ ]
hey why you killed bobby lupo
i thought i'd ask you that because you
just said it like you don't know who
killed the
brother she's gonna send me
all these rappers
all these rappers why did he say that
all these rappers are hoes whoa what do
you mean what
bear man dishing out their body and and
getting out yourself
what what's going on or what what this
stuff we don't know what he knows man he
knows
man doing different stuff sucking oden
ah please leave me alone i don't want to
go into it
she's gonna send me low code
[ __ ] i don't wanna draw me out
try to test my
[Music]
cut the big mac thing and then you
showed the ice in the [ __ ] phantom
you're taking the piss man's living life
now like
man's done his time in it so now he's
just living it like
[ __ ] it matey's yeah boom big mac i
can't remember last time i got a big map
and it wouldn't draw me out
why try to test my gangster with the
raps
said it was a cocaine rapper i just
could have brought two big macs tell
them i don't want ice in my fan oh
[ __ ] you always think i'm cheating cause
i'm in a car with zappos
[Music]
he's always cheating because he's in a
car with slappers well i tell you what
if i was in a car then gal as well and
they're yakking on jews
looking at man like that all dressed up
in their little silky wear
curly hair face all done hairs on fleek
skins on fleek lips look like they can
suck a whole looper dick
i should have said that i know but i did
you know what i mean in it like
of course your gal is going to bug out
they look like they're ready to go but
they look like twins
girls are good good to go [ __ ] you
always thinks i'm cheating cheating cuz
i'm in a car with slappers slappers
unlicensed
[Music]
no you know i don't rock with stitches i
guess i'm just too old-fashioned
whoa you see them gallery with phones
blood these guys are just there like yo
where are you boom pick you up bam get
in the whip bow roll no one use their
phones for nothing whatever happens
stays in the car
[Music]
you know
[Music]
so back in the day mandan told you it
was shoplifting
now he's shot lifts in harrods is he
really shoplifting
i think he's joking i don't think he
shot lifts there i think he actually
pays for his [ __ ]
but saying that we don't know macinny is
actually going in there
like i don't think he would but then he
just got that that face he just looks
like he he keeps up [ __ ] bloody don't
look like a tat to really [ __ ] with like
that guess i'm just too old-fashioned
[Music]
and you know hey what the [ __ ] going
on there blood
this guy is nuts blood this is looking
like a nine you know
this is looking like a nine right now
and the thing just cut out
battery died on me how dare did it just
went off
i see the panic in him
all right boom we're back obviously
harry's just gone and run and got the
charger but yeah but we're good we're
gonna go
straight back and use a lot lifting
little little shoplifting patterns
[Music]
you can't trust no one blocked
everything's blessed next minute man
chatting
[ __ ] by a man's back but this is why
yeah
a lot of people don't have bear man in
their circle fam
rolling with three is a crowd they say
you got your right and you put your left
yeah
and that's it you get me so just make
sure you know
the number one rule is um your enemies
what's it again keep your enemies keep
your friends closer
closer yeah that's it what he just said
he enemies
um far away i mean closer than your
friends or something i don't know i
don't get that [ __ ] but yeah that's what
the same was
one minute everything diary and the next
minute everything eerie
loved ones really tell them you can see
it all so clearly
see what i'm saying it'll be back on
road if it wasn't rapping and this is
what i mean
this is reason why man come off the road
because music or something what's
actually pushing them a dream like
something what motivates you it gives
you that drive
a goal like somewhere where you want to
something you want to become better than
what you are already do you see me
you [ __ ] up you knew you know what it
freaking means about that
and trip you over that means you ain't
walking again man put in a [ __ ] chair
blood don't let don't
ever get this brother upset blood i
can't even look in the camera while i'm
talking to you right now
because i don't know what harry's doing
with them boogers on what the what those
what what those what what the
trainers you're wearing bro they look
cool itch up on you blood
what are you talking about what size are
you free
i'm kidding i'm playing
[Music]
my brother we got kenny as well
[Music]
now this was gone i can't lie this one
was cold
yeah oh hey kaz make sure
make sure when i see my man give me a
little nice three five as well
man i started out the thing for the
people on the ends and things hey
look a shout out as well someone want me
three five inaudible
beauty but yeah boom as for potter you
got yourself
um that was sick can you all stars
always you know what you're doing family
i'm gonna come in there one day as well
shell it down let everyone know i've got
bars as well
um i i rated that at nine that's a big
nine so
yeah ma'am love potter do your things
they're a [ __ ] prison brother
you need to be honest music thing is
there for you love